("Justice Creed")
- [Man with Glasses] Rum raisin.
- [Woman with Short Hair] Mmmm, golly
they give a (bleep) about their Kit Kats.
- The packaging's so lovely,
but it's so deceiving.
I don't know what I'm about to eat.
- Definitely smells very strongly of rum.
- Oh, hell yes.
- Oh.
- [Man in Glasses] This taste a lot like
Captain Morgan in a Kit Kat.
- [Man with Beard] It tastes like there's
a shot of rum in this Kit Kat.
And I'm just gonna be sober.
I can drive home after I
eat a whole box of this.
- [Woman in Scarf] A
(speaking in Japanese) blend.
Which means citrus golden blend flavor.
- Have a break, have a Kit Kat.
It's funny, it's like not quite
give me a break, give me a Kit Kat.
- That smells like that's
citrus right there.
- Hmmmm.
- This is delicious.
- It kinda tastes like a creamsicle.
- First you get some orange,
then it gets very lemony.
- This isn't your ever day Kit Kat.
This is like a...
- And then you're like,"Is
that lime that I taste?"
- When you wanna spice things
up a little bit Kit Kat.
This is like you're
introducing role playing
into the bedroom kinda Kit Kat.
- [Man with Glasses] The
hot Japanese chili flavor.
- [Woman with Scarf] Hot
Japanese chili flavor.
Maybe it's just for sexy Japanese people.
- This box looks very dangerous.
- This is just straight up dark chocolate.
What does the pepper mean...
Oh, wait, (laughs) oh yeah it's spice, oh.
- Oh, oh.
- Yeah, you found it.
This is the best Kit Kat ever.
- It's getting a little spicy now.
Give it like a minute.
It's like a minute chocolate.
- It's like a hint of spice,
but it's a perfect hint of spice.
- No, you think it's dark chocolate,
and then habam!
- I wanna hug the guy who invented this.
- [Man with Glasses] Pile
of purple rope flavored.
- [Woman with Short
Hair] Woah, it's purple
sweet potato flavor.
- From the box, it looks like a Kit Kat
from like a nightmare that
Willy Wonka would have.
- It doesn't taste like anything.
- Oh, it's taro.
Purple sweet potato, right? Yeah.
- It doesn't taste like flowers,
it doesn't taste like potatoes.
- Nothing about this tastes
like potato or purple.
- If you like taro you'll like this.
If you don't, and you're
just like, "The (bleep)?"
It's vaguely sweet and tastes
kind of like ice cream.
But it's good.
- [Man in Glasses] What? What?
What are you?
- Oh come on, this is so ridiculous.
Why do you have to heat up candy?
- This looks like duck poop.
- It tastes like maple syrup.
- It's like cinnamony.
It smells like a candle.
It's like you walk into
your grandma's house
and this is the smell.
She just burning Kit Kats.
- It is like creme brulee.
- I mean it's delicious, but like why?
Why?
- No one's gonna be heating up a Kit Kat.
I'm gonna tell you this right now.
No one in America is gonna
be heating up a Kit Kat.
- It's probably the most
delicious Kit Kat I've ever had,
to be honest.
- It's delicious, but
they take their Kit Kats
so goddamn seriously over there.
- I think there's something about knowing
your place in the world.
And a Kit Kat you should not try and
elevate itself to a baked pastry.
(Whistling Kit Kat theme song)